ああ
もうなぁ
留学はいいんだよ楽しいか
いろんな外国人のそうまずもできたし
楽しいんだけど
辞表が多い大学より大変な気がしてならないんですよもう学校
まあ一に耳がいいんですよ
1日サボって
今日は一人でイギリスをブラブラしていましたごめんなさい
イギリスいいんですよこの公園もすごい蹴れると思うんですけど
地協がめんどくさいんですっ
ホームステイの家から学校が遠くて
もう
大変もこの公園のきれいな風景を映した後かな後にお知らせがあるんで
あとりあえずもうちょっとだけかなきれいな公園の
みて下さいお願いします
あっハゲだ
あげたいっ
うんうん
goo
こちら外れ社長です
はいみなさんお気づきの通り
もうすぐ
チャンネル登録者が10万人いくということで
本当にありがとうございます
お久しぶりに
皆さんが参加できる動画を2万人きれいにやろうと思いまして
皆さんにお願いがあります一言で言うと
皆さんに
じゃあなってやってほしいんです
まあ10万人記念ということでなんかみんなでじゃあなってする動画を作れたらいい
なって思いまして
ぜひ皆さんよかったら僕に
ザーなんてやってる動画を送ってください詳しい話は動画の説明欄にあるんですけど
まぁ簡単に言うと僕のメールに皆さんがじゃあなって言ってるどうかを見ずできるだけ
短いやつを送っていただきたいです
悪いことには使わないというのと僕の動画に出るかもしれないですよっていう2点が
あるんでそこをご了承
その上ていただくとありがたいです
気づいたら妻んにんですよ
どうするんですか見方を見せましょう
ん
じゃんはいもう今の感じでいいねぇ
本当にもう適当でいいんだよもちレイズとりあえずも数々行歩数で風が欲しいとか言っ
ちゃダメですけどたまには参加していいんじゃないかな
もう youtube やってる人とかでもぜひ
6て欲しいんでん
じゃあ本当じゃあなっているだけでいいんでよろしくお願いします
このメールに添付ファイルファイル添付して
送っていただくとありがたいです宜しくお願いします
ん